intermission finally over the beatles
love by cirque is making its grand
return to the mirage this evening las
vegas now host jillian is there to kick
off the exciting return hi
[Music]
jillian hey you guys yes love is in the
air at the mirage tonight we are kicking
off the grand reopening of beetles love
by cirque du soleil the show has been
gone for over a year during the pandemic
so we are so excited to welcome the cast
back and let me tell you the energy is
exciting here the cash just did a full
performance through the mirage if you
take a look around people are lining up
to get their tickets shows will start
again from thursday through sunday 7 pm
and 9 30 p.m and let me just tell you
personal preference here i have seen the
show a few times and this is one that
you do not want to miss so come down to
the mirage this weekend check out the
new show and the cast has been working
hard if you head over to the cirque du
soleil instagram you can actually see
some behind the scenes photos of the
cast getting in full makeup so i tuned
into that before i came down tonight so
i think the only thing left to do here
tonight is come together
right now
all right we'll leave the singing to the
beatles i'll send it back to you guys